adam i'm going to go to your favorite
story today
yeah southwest pilot sentenced
for watching porn mid-flight committing
loot act
okay very important i asked adam and tom
right before the whole thing what is
your favorite story guess what adam said
porn that's his favorite story great
let's address it it's it's a catastrophe
he's a pilot southwest pilot sentence
for watching porn midflight committing
loot act new york post a southwest
airlines pilot who was watching porn
exposes generals to a female officer
on a flight to florida has been
sentenced for to one year probation
michael hack 60 apologized before u.s
magistrate
judge mark coulson ordered him on friday
to serve
probation and pay 5 000 fine the
incident occurred on a flight that was
he was piloting from philadelphia to
orlando from august 10 2020 prosecutors
federal prosecutors said when the plane
reached cruising altitude hawk got out
of the pilot seat and disrobed
and began watching pornographic material
on a laptop computer on the cockpit
prosecutor said
haku retired shortly after the incident
was charged in april intentionally
committing the dude
indecent or obscene act in a public
place he pleaded guilty to all charges
adam since it's your story oh yeah this
is my story well this uh certainly puts
uh flying in the cockpit
a little to the perspective
that's good i mean yeah so this guy
maybe took that the cockpit thing too
literal
but you can't make this crap up and i pl
as i was reading the story i'm thinking
to myself
please tell me this wasn't in florida
please tell me if this wasn't in florida
and flight goes from uh
philly to orlando florida ah florida
does it again florida man
this time it was actually the pilot in
the in the cockpit
and then obviously right after the story
comes out he's retired he's decided to
retire he's 60 years old it's time for
him to retire
and he's put out the pasture so uh talk
about
just the the definition of cancer
culture
the me too the meat shame on these guys
the me too
canceling a pilot meaning pathetic
meaning
this is let the man let the man disrobe
i mean but this is everything
that's wrong everything that's wrong in
america right now
was literally done in this cockpit right
here
the metoo movement the cancer culture
the they all have a point here
and um this is anything
very important talk about having your
hand on a different joystick as you're
planning uh flying the plane
you know i don't find anything about
this story funny i mean even though it's
humorous this guy makes me sick
he really truly does i mean you are an
experienced pilot
with 150 souls as sully would say right
yeah
you're responsible i mean could you ima
i mean can you imagine a real pilot
how disgusted they are by this i'm
disgusted by everything this creep
i think he got off easy i guarantee you
he got off i guarantee you this
his the pilot's union is gonna put a
little cocoon around him and protect him
also if i'm a pilot i am so pissed off
at this guy because here's my reaction
you don't do [ __ ] when you fly a plane
it's all automated so you have time to
look at porn
all right that just goes to show that
everything is computerized and automated
you're not even flying this thing the
whole thing is so wack so weird and to
think that he only got supervised
probation or whatever he has and a five
thousand dollar fine
and then did you hear how he described
it uh here's the quote from southwest
uh another nothing to the left southwest
did investigate investigate the matter
and as a result
ceased paying mr hawk any benefits he
was entitled to as a result of his
separation from the airline
but he says it was like a simultaneous
prank that he was doing
gotcha i don't know too many other 60
year old women that find that money
so anyway i think the guy's a perv
i'm just wondering what his other fellow
co-pilots have to say because this
guy's been flying if he's 60 years old
he's probably been flying for 30 years
or so
and all these other pilots like oh
that's just hawk doing what hawk do
just exposing his genitals yeah i just i
just know
moving forward every time on a flight
i'm first class and i see
the pilot going to the bathroom all i'm
going to think about is i know what he's
doing right now
okay or
but here's the thing let me ask you a
question what if the story was different
what if the story was flight attendant
and pilot caught
is that different would you have judged
it differently like they were basically
on the cockpit going up they were mile
high club in it what would you would you
have said salute to the
what would you have said would you have
high five you know what i mean
i'm going to say you guys have so much
down time go do it in the hotel
i mean do it in the shuttle bus going
back and forth just because i found
their lives a mile high up
what do you mean what other time do i
have i got to say something yeah we're
talking about the mile high
mile high club you ever you ever uh mile
high uh
these are two married men sitting at
yesterday come on man you okay you tell
us
yeah i've attempted to it's just too
small
the pilot was too busy flying the plane
like i'd rather just
you know dark plain in your seat
whatever but private is piece of cake
just so you know well yeah okay but when
you're when you're not private well you
mean mandatory if the door closes that
is a that is a good point you just tell
the pilot gentlemen can you close that
door
yeah i think the mile high club is a
little overrated the gross little
bathroom people are waiting we were
knocking
yeah i mean you got to get it done at
one point in your life but
harmless doing this yeah no no when
the moment it involves exposing to
another person like flight attendant now
you're just
you know you're you're an idiot to do
something like this there's no
difference between this and some of
these stories you hear about some
comedians went through some
athletes go through you're putting
yourself in a situation like that if
you're doing that it's a mistake
you got to think about it it was exposed
to a female officer i assume that's the
co-pilot is that what that means yeah so
she must have been the person that
ratted him out yeah
exactly so i want to get her perspective
on this you know who knows what happened
there who knows what happened all i can
say is if this
if this was two folks going at it in the
cockpit would you have judged it
differently
well do you think it's it might be
happening for all you know
i already mentioned i bet your pilots
are sitting there saying what is this
guy talking about like this is story
what are you talking about this happens
every day we spend a half a year
mile high where do you expect us to do
something in the hotel after that anyway
so adam i hope you're grateful for us
here and your favorite stories
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye